ich rufe nun auf den zusatzpunkt 5 sowie
tagesordnungspunkt 30
beratung des antrags der fraktion der
cdu/csu mit dem titel den traum von den
eigenen vier wänden ermöglichen
sowie beratung der beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für klimaschutz und
energie zu dem entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu zu der abgabe
einer regierungserklärung durch den
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz zu dem thema für eine sozial
ökologische marktwirtschaft
transformation innovativ gestalten
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
2022 für die beschlussempfehlung zu dem
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu werden wir später namentlich
abstimmen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten vereinbart ich bitte sie
die platzwechsel jetzt vorzunehmen
und wir nutzen fix die gelegenheit ihn
ein zwei sätze noch zusagen zum jetzt
folgenden tagesordnungspunkte dem unter
anderem ein antrag der unionsfraktion
zugrunde liegt dem traum von den eigenen
vier wänden ermöglichen hatte bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas schon vorgetragen
erster redner hier wird sein jan marco
luczak aus eben der unionsfraktion es
geht unter anderem um vorteile für alle
diejenigen die energieeffizient neu
bauen wollen
das ist gelebte freiheit das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat das mal
sehr schön in die worte gekleidet das
eigentum die wirtschaftliche basis für
individuelle freiheit ist und das ist
auch so und eigentum ein eigenheim das
ist noch viel mehr das ist eine gute
altersvorsorge ist sicherheit
unabhängigkeit vor steigenden mieten die
unabhängigkeit vor inflation und
deswegen ist es auch nicht verwunderlich
dass millionen von menschen in unserem
land davon träumen vier von fünf träumen
diesen traum von den eigenen vier wänden
die wahrheit aber leider ist das sich
viel zu wenige menschen diesen trauben
auch verwirklichen lassen er bleibt ein
traum deutschland ist in europa
schlusslicht bei der eigentumsquote und
das gilt gerade für junge familien gilt
für menschen mit geringen oder mittleren
einkommen sie alle träumen diesen traum
aber eher zerplatzt allzu oft an
steigenden kosten beim bauen am zu wenig
bauland zur verfügung steht und manchmal
eben auch an den politischen
rahmenbedingungen und
dann müsste es ja eigentlich wenn man
das hört dass millionen menschen davon
träumen eigentlich ausfluss einer guten
einer bürgernahen politik sein
darauf zu reagieren diesen menschen das
zu ermöglichen diesen traum von den
eigenen vier wänden auch wirklich zu
leben wenn man jetzt mal gucken was
macht denn die ampel an der stelle da
muss man leider konstatieren das ist
eine große leerstelle die die ampel an
dieser stelle hat im koalitionsvertrag
im koalitionsvertrag wenn wir demnächst
da gab es noch höhere ziele es gab wohl
klingende versprechen das man
eigenkapital einsetzen darin machen
möchte zins verblieben und viele viele
sachen mehr dir den richtigen weg
eingeschlagen hätte und ich war
ehrlicherweise auch ganz positiv
überrascht als ich das gelesen habe wenn
man sich jetzt noch mal die realität
anschaut was bleibt eigentlich davon
übrig muss man feststellen nichts nichts
bleibt von diesen hehren zielen und wo
kriegen dem versprechen ruhig denn was
macht die ampel im haushalt gibt es
keinen eigenen ansatz um das thema
eigentumsbildung die förderung von
jungen familie an dieser stelle nach
vorne zu bringen ganz im gegenteil wir
wissen schon dass das baukindergeld
eine maßnahme die wir als union auf den
weg gebracht haben wo viele
hunderttausende familien von profitiert
haben was sie einer riesengroßen
beliebtheit erfreut dass das
wahrscheinlich so sein wird dass viele
familien die antrags förderberechtigt
sind am ende leer ausgehen weil die
gelder nicht bereitgestellt werden wir
haben erlebt dass wir einen kfw
förderstopp gehabt haben der massiv
vertrauen zerstört hat der jungen
familien auf den weg in die eigenen vier
wände die grundlage ihrer finanzierung
unter den boden werfen und wir sehen
dass die bau ministerin die ja
eigentlich die erste wäre die diese
maßnahmen nach vorne bringen müsste die
in zeitungsinterviews sich einlässt und
sagt na ja also der bau von neuen
einfamilienhäuser das sei ja ökologisch
und ökonomisch unsinnig meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen
verdammt ich sage ihnen das sind die
völlig falschen weichen stimmen das sind
die falschen signale wir müssen das
gegenteil machen wir müssen mehr
menschen in die eigenen vier wände
bringen und das versäumen sie mit ihrer
politik
und das greifen sie auch als union in
einem papier wo wir neun punkte
herausgearbeitet haben was die richtigen
weichenstellungen haben um genau dieses
zeit dieses ziel traum von den eigenen
vier wänden zu ermöglichen da geht es
darum dass wir eine verlässliche einer
auskömmlich und eine nachhaltige
kfw-förderung auf den weg bringen die
diesen dreiklang ermöglicht neue
eigentumsbildung klimaschutz und
gleichzeitig dann auch bezahlbare mieten
das werden wir nur hinkriegen wenn
dieses förderkreis dieses hin und her
beim kaffee endlich aufhört und die
menschen die bauherren planungs und
investitionssicherheit haben dass sie
auf den weg sich machen können um neu zu
bauen bezahlbar zu blöd energieeffizient
zu bauen und nicht das wir jetzt haben
diesen atlantis muss dass alle projekte
zurückgestellt werden weil die keiner
weiß wie es denn eigentlich weitergeht
sie müssen endlich klarheit schaffen wie
es weitergeht mit der karte förderung
und natürlich müssen wir vor allem bei
den nebenkosten runterkommen und dann
möchte ich ins tor und die
grunderwerbsteuer adressieren das ist
eine steuer die in den letzten jahren
vom aufgaben enorm angestiegen ist wir
prognostizieren dass etwa 20 22 ein
volumen von etwa 18 milliarden euro bei
der grunderwerbssteuer geben ist ja klar
weil die kaufkosten sich sogar dem wir
preislich so entwickeln steigt diese
steuer aber das ist gerade etwas was
eine riesige hürde ist gerade für junge
familien diese nebenkosten kriegen sie
nicht finanziert die finanziert ihnen
keine bank deswegen brauchen sie dort
eigenkapital und wir wissen doch alle
dass menschen mit geringen mit mittleren
einkommen junge familien denen fehlt
dieses eigenkapital und deswegen sagen
wir als und wir brauchen für selbst
genutztes wohneigentum da brauchen wir
freibeträge familienfreundlich
ausgestaltet dass auch junge menschen
familien endlich diesen traum leben
können und deswegen sage ich das nochmal
ihr bundesfinanzminister jetzt
bundeskanzlers der hat das in der
letzten wahlperiode verschleppt hat sich
nicht mit den länder aus werden das muss
jetzt endlich anders werden wir brauchen
diese freibeträge bei der
grunderwerbsteuer
von den letzten punkt den ich nur ganz
kurz abgeben möchte uns geht es vor
allen dingen darum auch viele
mieterinnen und mietern endlich die
möglichkeit die chance zu geben eigentum
und herren und deswegen setzen wir uns
für staatlich abgesicherte mietkauf
modelle ein dass man über eine lange
frist statt miete alleine zu zahlen in
die eigene tasche ins eigene
portemonnaie zahlen kannte wohl leisten
kann und am ende als mieter auch die
chance hat eigentümer zu r wir brauchen
eine gemeinsame kraftanstrengung ich
will hier wollen als union dass
deutschland kein land von träumen bleibt
sondern dass es ein land von eigentümer
wird unterstützen uns dabei wir sind
dazu bereit wir haben die richtigen
konzepte vorgelegt deswegen unterstützen
sie unseren antrag vielen dank
sagt jan marco luczak der sprecher für
wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen in der unionsfraktion und er
wird eine direkte antwort bekommen auf
seine forderungen von klara geywitz der
zuständigen ministerin
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe cdu fraktion ganz
herzlichen dank für diesen antrag ich
glaube angesichts der vielen
herausforderung die wir gerade im
bausektor haben es ist ja gut dass wir
uns die zeit nehmen darüber zu sprechen
wie es die menschen in diesem land
schaffen ab preiswerten wohnraum für
sich zu finden wie wir neubau fördern
können die wir diesen jungen fördern
können das kann man sehr ruhig und
sachlich miteinander besprechen ich bin
ja auch dafür bekannt dass ich
eigentlich eher eine ruhige person bin
an der stelle möchte ich aber doch mal
eine emotion äußeren herr dr es ist für
mich nicht ganz nachvollziehbar dass
mich der hat sich verkürzt zitieren sie
sagen ich hätte was dagegen die häuser
zu bauen weil das ökonomisch und
ökologisch unsinnig ist das wäre in der
tat etwas verwunderlich wenn die
ministerin grundsätzlich probleme mit
dem bauen hat deswegen bitte ich dass
sie auch das zitat nochmal nachlesen da
stand es ist ökonomisch und ökologisch
unsinnig wenn jede generation ihre
eigenen eigenheim gebaut und
gesagt das ist jetzt nicht so
revolutionär dass ich der erste mensch
der auf diese idee gekommen ist sondern
wir haben in deutschland seit
jahrhunderten die tradition das
natürlich häuser von einer familien die
nächst gefeiert werden das ist ganz klar
ist dass man sein elternhaus hat das
umbaut dass man es modernisiert und das
was heute passiert ist doch dass viele
menschen nicht mehr in dem dorf wurden
in dem ihre eltern wohnen und das heißt
dass die wenn sie ein eigenes haus haben
erst mal daran denken ich baue neues das
alter der eltern ist ja nicht da wo man
gut so und das ist was wir adressieren
müssen wir haben seit dem krieg tausende
von einfamilienhäusern gebaut in denen
keine familien mehr leben sondern die
dann
demnächst auch zeugung weiterverkauf
anstehen wir haben ein riesiges
sanierungsstau in diesem bereich der
gebäude sektors ein großes problem bei
der erreichung der klimaziele und in der
tat haben wir sehr viele familien die
nachvollziehbarer weise davon träumen
dass sie ein eigenes häuschen mit garten
haben ich als mutter von drei kindern
kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen aber
wie bringen wir denn diese beiden
gesellschaftlichen sachen zusammen die
vielen häuser die es schon gibt im
bestand die alle eine neue heizung
brauchen die gedämmt werden müssen die
energetisch saniert werden müssen und
die nachvollziehbare wunsch ist eine
sache das ganz einfach nämlich eine
sanierungsförderung dass wir einen
anreiz setzen dass die jungen familien
auch darüber nachdenken sich ein
wunderschönes bestands auszuwählen und
für ihre bedürfnisse umzubauen und wir
waren ja ich war ja bei ihnen
herr dr ich war ja bei ihnen in der
fraktion in der arbeitsgruppe vielen
dank auch für die gute diskussion dort
und da haben wir gemeinsam ja zum
beispiel das von ihnen erwähnte programm
jung kauft alt gesprochen das ist etwas
was es schon gibt was wir gerne stärken
wollen und es gibt auch in der wg
sanierungsförderung da einen großen
anreiz dass man jetzt schon sagt ja ich
erwerbe und mein ziel ist es mit den
modellen die wir entwickeln werden für
die eigentumsförderung das ist eine
feste verabredung sie haben im
koalitionsvertrag erwähnt dass wir da
auf einen schwerpunkt setzen auf diesen
jungs förderung
ein weiterer punkt den wir umsetzen
werden dass die anhebung der linearen
abschreibung von 2 auf 3 prozent und ich
denke es ist sicherlich auch nicht
entgangen dass der kollege christian
linder gerade sehr intensiv dabei ist
mit den ländern darüber zu sprechen wie
sich die gründer werk steuer so
entwickelt wie sie das auf angedeutet
haben dass die länder in der lage sind
auch differenzierte hebesätze zu machen
es ist ja so die meisten menschen bauen
sich nur ein einziges mal in ihrem leben
ein haus und da kann man dann darüber
auch nachdenken einen anderen
grunderwerbsteuer hebesatz zu nehmen
wichtig ist und das war gestern viele
von ihnen waren ja auch dabei beim tag
der bauindustrie dass wir jetzt
reagieren auf die baukosten steigen und
es ist natürlich nicht denkbar dass wir
sämtliche baumaterialien so
funktionieren aber wir müssen überlegen
wie wir in dieser situation dämpfend auf
die baukosten einwirken können und da
ist ein wichtiger punkt die ganze frage
der modernisierung der bauindustrie in
zehn jahren werden baustellen anders
aussehen mit weniger fachkräften und
mehr technisierung mit mehr
digitalisierung und wir werden natürlich
mit anderen baumaterialien arbeiten ein
wichtiger punkt auch zur kostendämpfung
ist die ganze entwicklung sehr jenes
bauen modulares bauen typisierte bauen
und ja das lied dann auch schön aus ja
das kann man auch mit nachhaltigen
materialien machen und nein das sieht
nicht aus wie den siebziger jahren
ich lade alle dazu ein das wir gerade in
diesem punkt auf die länder zugehen sie
wissen die bauordnung das ist 16 mal
unterschiedlich in deutschland wenn sie
wirklich
kosteneinsparung mit typisierten baum
machen dann muss es natürlich möglich
sein denselben typ von hamburg bis nach
münchen zu bauen da werden wir mit den
kollegen in den ländern sprechen müssen
ich habe es ja auch eingeladen im
bündnis für unbezahlbar ausbauen und ich
würde mich auch sehr freuen der doktor
luczak wenn ich dann auch auf sie
zugehen könnte auf die unionsfraktion
dass wir wie in die wesentlichen
bestimmungen der bauordnung dann auch in
deutschland vereinheitlichen um die
bauindustrie von unnötiger bürokratie zu
entlasten heißt es nicht an der debatte
sagt klara geywitz die
bundesbauministerium die auch wiederholt
in ihrem beitrag betont hat wie
positiv sehe dem austausch mit der
unionsfraktion zu sehen wird marc
bernhard ist der nächste redner aus der
fdp fraktion unter ist der bau und
wohnungspolitischer sprecher
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die mieten sind ganz oben und das
vertrauen in die regierung ganz unten
ein halbes jahr ampel regierung hat
genügt um den traum vieler menschen von
den eigenen vier wänden gründlich zu
zerstören im januar haben sie von der
regierung die kfw förderung von heute
auf morgen ohne irgendeine vorwarnung
eine woche vor dem offiziellen ende
einfach gestoppt und damit viele tausend
familien
die eigenen vier wände gestohlen
menschen
die bereits viele zehntausend euro in
architektenpläne
energieberater
grundstückskauf baugenehmigungen
grunderwerbsteuer notarkosten und so
weiter bezahlt haben und sich auf ihr
förder versprechen verlassen haben
viele von diesen menschen stehen jetzt
wegen dieser regierung mit vielen
tausend euro schulden da ohne hoffnung
sich die eigenen vier wände noch leisten
zu können und diejenigen die sich noch
leisten konnten für viele weitere 1000
euro
die baupläne und die energetische
planung so zu ändern dass sie ihren
neuen förderprogramm nach kfw 40
standard entsprechen haben sie nun
endgültig am boden zerstört indem sie
ihr vor ihren neues förder versprechen
nach gerade mal drei stunden ohne
jegliche vorwarnung gestoppt haben sie
haben also innerhalb kürzester zeit das
vertrauen und damit den traum von den
eigenen vier wänden für viele menschen
ruiniert und
jetzt
wollen gerade ausgerechnet sie von der
union die in der vorgängerregierung
dieses ganze desaster mit verursacht hat
angeblich den traum von den eigenen vier
wänden ermöglichen
schönes dass sie dafür den fdp antrag
aus dem jahr 2018 offensichtlich gelesen
und vieles wichtige daraus abgeschrieben
haben was sie damals als regierung
abgelehnt haben wollen sie also jetzt
angeblich selber umsetzen
ihre scheinheiligkeit geht aber noch
weiter denn natürlich ist es richtig
dass die grunderwerbsteuer wie von uns
seit jahren gefordert gesenkt werden
muss ganz besonders für junge familien
aber es waren doch gerade sie von der
union die die grunderwerbsteuer immer
weiter in die höhe getrieben hat bereits
die unionsgeführte regierung unter
helmut kohl bereits 1997 die
grunderwerbsteuer von 2 auf 3,5 prozent
erhöht und es war die unionsgeführte
regierung unter angela merkel die es
2006 den bundesländern ermöglicht hat
die grundsteuer selbstständig weiter zu
erhöhen und die erhöhungen sind
natürlich postwendend auch gekommen und
besonders peinlich muss ich schon mal
sagen für den antrag ist aber dass
gerade die cdu regierten länder
nordrhein-westfalen und
schleswig-holstein heute den höchsten
grunderwerbssteuer satz in deutschland
haben nämlich 6,5 prozent wenn sie also
wenn sie also die menschen wirklich
entlassen entlasten wollen würden dann
hätten sie doch 16 jahre dafür zeit
gehabt 16 jahre nichts gemacht und in
den von ihnen regierten ländern könnten
sie über noch sofort handeln und die
grunderwerbsteuer auf 3,5 prozent senken
das sieht jetzt nicht tun daran sieht
man dass es sich bei ihrem antrag um
nichts an als ein billiges
schaufensterantrag ohne jegliche
substanz handelt
die deutsche bundesbank stellt fest das
größte hindernis für die vier eigenen
vier wände die hohen grunderwerbsteuer
in deutschland sind und deren höhe ist
die direkte folge der unionspolitik der
letzten jahre die cdu ist also das
größte hindernis für den traum von den
eigenen vier wänden hier in deutschland
und es sieht man auch ganz klar und
deutlich bei den wohnungsbau kosten in
16 jahren merkel sind die kosten des
wohnens durch unzählige komplizierte
bauvorschriften und energetische
vorgaben geradezu explodiert teure
heizungsanlagen in bremen extreme
wärmeschutzverglasungen zweifelhafte dem
vorschriften die einen regelrechten
dämpfern ausgelöst haben über 500
milliarden euro styropor wurden auch
deutsche häuser geklebt ohne dass es
laut deutschen wirtschaftsinstitut
irgendeinen nutzen gehabt hätte wenn die
union jetzt in ihrem antrag die von ihr
selbst eingeführten kosten 300
anforderungen angeblich senken will dann
ist es nichts als blanker hohn
tatsache ist
dass er neu gebauter quadratmeter in
deutschland an wohnfläche heute im
schnitt 3400 euro kostet und das ganze
zu einer kaltmiete von mindestens 13
euro 50 für und es können sich geben 80
prozent der menschen in unserem land
nicht leisten
deutschland hat also nicht ohne grund
ist nicht ohne grund schluss nicht in
europa aus die wohneigentumsquote
betrifft sondern die deutsche bundesbank
stellt klar fest dass die
wohnungspolitik der regierung dafür
verantwortlich ist dass unsere
wohneigentumsquote die niedrigste in
ganz europa ist nämlich gerade mal 45
prozent während der europäische
durchschnitt deutlich über 70 liegt wir
wollen deutschland von einem land der
mieter zu einem land der eigentümer
machen und darum fordern wir erstens
alle kostentreibenden bauvorschriften
müssen auf ein erträgliches maß
reduziert um kostentreiber eliminiert
werden
zweitens die abschaffung der grundsteuer
das wäre nämlich der sofortige
entlastung für jeden haushalt in unserem
land von 400 bis 500 euro pro jahr
drittens eine generelle absenkung der
grunderwerbsteuer auf 3,5 prozent und
viertens eine komplette grunderwerb
steuerbefreiung für die ersten selbst
genutzten eigenen vier wände
und liebe kollegen liebe kollegen von
der union es macht doch einfach viel
mehr sinn den anträgen der afg gleich
zuzustimmen statt sie erst abzulehnen
und dann hier als plagiat wieder
einzubringen herzlichen dank
ich komme kurz kurz zurück zu
tagesordnungspunkt 27 die zeit für die
namentliche abstimmung ist gleich vorbei
ich möchte daher fragen ist noch ein
mitglied des hauses anwesend das noch
nicht abgestimmt hat
das sieht nicht danach aus dann würde
ich die abstimmung jetzt schließen und
bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer im moment einer einer
rennt noch oder 2
dann warten wir das noch kurz ab und
dann rufe ich aber in der zeit
die nächste rednerin auch für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen dr sandra
peter
ja sehr verehrt der präsident in meiner
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen wohnen
ist so viel mehr als ein dach überm kopf
und wo und wie wir wohnen entscheidet
darüber ob wir uns als teil dieser
gesellschaft fühlen ob wir wurzeln
schlagen und ja ob wir uns frei fühlen
und
nein der markt regelt leider nicht die
versorgung mit bezahlbaren
klimafreundlichen sozial durch wüssten
wo daumen alleine
das ist die bittere erkenntnis aus den
die regulierungs fehlern der 1990 er
jahre der rückzug des bundes damals aus
der wohnraumförderung oder auch der
verkauf der kommunalen
wohnungsgesellschaften die wir gesehen
haben sie haben dazu geführt dass der
wohnraummangel heute eine der sozialen
fragen unserer zeit ist und darum ist es
genau richtig dass die ampel koalition
die wohnungspolitik ins zentrum ihrer
politik stellen
ja dabei ist natürlich die bedeutung der
grauen energie im gebäudesektor ganz
enorm und wenn wir uns jetzt gemeinsam
auf den weg gemacht haben richtung
klimaneutralität dann ist es auch ganz
entscheidend dass wir in zukunft
klimafreundlich bauen und
klimafreundlich sanieren und genau
dieses problem adressiert doch jetzt die
neue kfw förderung der bundesregierung
für effiziente gebäude ist es so dass
jetzt ab dem 22 neben die neuen anträge
für das kfw punkte haben 40 gestellt
werden konnten nachdem das programm eben
nicht von der alten regierung aus
finanziert worden ist und das war das
problem das wir jetzt haben es umgehend
adressiert worden und deswegen sind wir
jetzt in dem zweiten schritt dieses
programm zyklus jetzt können anträge
gestellt werden die auch die kriterien
für nachhaltiges bauen erfüllen und da
ist ganz wichtige weiterentwicklung
jetzt drin weil ich denke schon dass wir
uns hier in diesem hause unter
demokratinnen und demokraten einig sind
dass wir genau da natürlich rein gehen
wollen mit der staatlichen finanzierung
wo die wertvollen steuer euros auch den
größten effekt haben und genau das ist
jetzt in dem fall vorhanden
ab 20 23 dann werden wir neues
umfassendes programm mit dem titel
klimafreundliches bauen auflegen mit dem
besonders auch die
treibhausgasemissionen über den
kompletten lebenszyklus eines gebäudes
stärker im fokus sind und ich glaube da
werden wichtige schritte gemacht um eben
auch den bausektor in die
klimaneutralität zu integrieren siebe
union sie sehen die guten ideen in ihren
anträgen die haben wir in der umsetzung
die schlechten werden wir auch weiter
den bürgerinnen und bürgern ersparen und
ich glaube 1 zeichnet diese
förderpolitik aus der ampel wir
verbinden die anreize mit der ambition
herzlichen dank
sandra dezember das aus der dose
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen zum
unionsantrag zum thema wohnen förderung
von wohneigentum mit
jetzt hat bundestags präsidentin bärbel
war es auch die abstimmung zum eu zur eu
mission beziehungsweise der beteiligung
der bundeswehr daran
beendet geschlossen die stimmen werden
jetzt ausgezählt ihnen gut 15 bis 20
minuten wissen wir auch hier zu mehr es
wird wahrscheinlich nicht viel anders
ausfallen als das ergebnis zur un
mission zu mali nächster redner hier in
dieser debatte ist christi anleihe kommt
aus der linksfraktion und ist
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher dort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren das ist ja heute schon
ein seltsamer anlass da bemüht die union
den jahreswirtschaftsbericht weil dann
vollkommen überlaufen des bau förderte
gestoppt wurde das noch aus ihrer
eigenen amtszeit stammt ich meine sie
reden über häuslebauer und wenn sagen
wir mal eine facharbeiter familie ein
häuschen baut dann wollen wir ja auch
dass die sicherheit dabei haben aber bei
dem programm über das wir heute reden
waren 75 prozent der nicht genehmigten
anträge anträge von unternehmen und eben
nicht von menschen die den traum von den
eigenen vier wänden haben wie es in
ihrem antrag heißt und meine kollegin
caren lay schaut der
immobilienwirtschaft genau auf die
finger und da stellt sich für uns die
frage wie viele millionen von euro sind
eigentlich aus diesen fördertöpfen in
wohnungskonzern vivo novia geflossen
weil ich glaube nicht dass hier jemand
dort wohnt spaß macht das nicht das kann
ich ihnen sagen und dann wie die union
heute den rächer der arbeiterklasse und
das ist schon ein dickes ding und sie
geben an der ampel die schuld radiert
das programm jahr gestoppt und als neuer
abgeordneter denkt man sich da manchmal
hätte die union in den letzten jahren
mal im kanzleramt gesessen dann hätten
wir viele probleme heute nicht und ich
hatte da jetzt eine geheime botschaft an
sie versteckt in diesen worten haben sie
die gefunden sie haben dir von ok dann
zur ampel weil die drängenden probleme
werden ja auch von nicht angegangen wir
bräuchten 6,3 millionen sozialwohnungen
haben aber gerade mal noch eine
millionen sozialwohnungen es ist ein
historischer tiefstand und dann werden
energie gehäuse mit 18 milliarden euro
gefördert und durch eine anfrage von
meinem kollegen pascal leyser wissen wir
dass sie nicht wissen wie viel davon
eigentlich sozialer wohnungsbau war 18
milliarden euro gibt es für energie
häuser und für den sozialen wohnungsbau
gibt es zwei milliarden aber eine davon
heißt klima milliarden war die grünen
sind mit an bord und ampel da war jetzt
eine versteckte botschaft für sie drin
ja ich sage das weil ich bin ja eher so
der subtile typen
sohn einmal klartext wenn wir hier schon
mit dem jahreswirtschaftsbericht
so großes ballett tanzen dann sollte man
sich auch um die großen fragen kümmern
die die menschen da draußen beschäftigen
das ist nun mal eine energiepreis krise
und das ist eine inflation die den
menschen den boden unter den füßen
wegzieht die menschen zahlen bei jedem
wocheneinkauf die toben raufen sie angst
vor der nächsten heizkostenabrechnung
und darum muss es doch wir gehen und
nicht um die interessen der
bauwirtschaft sondern um die interessen
der menschen die uns gewählt haben meine
damen und herren
und der punkt es gibt im moment genügend
gas es liegt also nicht am mangelnden
angeboten eines werden ja sogar noch gas
vorräte angelegt und trotzdem steigen
die preise und da will ich ihnen noch
einen sucht ihren hinweis geben nämlich
geht es dabei um die energie
börse anfang des jahres brach der
wichtige gas terminkontrakt dax etf
plötzlich um die hälfte ein und warum
weil es aussichten auf gutes wetter gab
wegen einer verdammten wetterprognose
bricht ein wichtiger gas terminkontrakt
um die hälfte ein ja was glauben sie was
an der börse los ist wenn dann ein krieg
ausbricht und deswegen sagen der
spekulationen dort müssen verboten
werden das funktioniert nicht in einer
ergebniskrise und
deswegen schlagen wir als linke forderte
zu einer staatlichen kontrolle von
energiepreisen kommt dass der staat
kontrolliert was sind eigentlich die
erzeugerkosten was sind die
produktionskosten und das spekulationen
und krisengewinner verboten werden
wissen sie auch warum weil energie zur
daseinsvorsorge gehört in unserer
gesellschaft kann niemand ohne energie
leben oder kennen sie jemanden und weil
energiepreise die inflation treiben und
zwar doppelt einmal durch öl gas und
strom und einmal bei in allen anderen
produkten energie da drinsteckt und
deswegen sagen wir das recht auf profit
und das recht auf krisen gewinne von
einigen wenigen ist nicht höher als das
recht von allen anderen auf ein leben
ohne angst vor dem ende des monats
dankeschön
christi anleihe für die linksfraktion wo
er wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher ist
mit einem exkurs zum thema energiekosten
daniel fürst für die fdp-fraktion und
sie sehen das präsidium hat gewechselt
der bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
ist aydan özoguz gefolgt die
bundestagsvize
prägen frau kollegin heike ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass die union nicht
großes ballett tanz mit
wirtschaftsbericht die trumpet
unbeholfen durch den raum und das ist ja
auch der punkt ja
millionen menschen haben den traum vom
eigentum das ist ein gelebtes
aufstiegsversprechen ist eine
lebensleistung wohneigentum schafft
sicherheit schutz vor altersarmut nicht
nur die generationen dieser reichtum
auch generationen darüber hinaus und
vielleicht auch eine wichtige
informationen an den eher links
orientierten teil dieses plenums
wohneigentum schließt die
vermögensverteilung es ist sozial
gerecht und deswegen ist es für uns
freidemokraten völlig außer frage wir
wollen deutschland zu einer eigentümer
nation machen
aber auch den weg dahin muss
man ja feststellen ist noch viel zu tun
der luchs sie wissen die eigentumsquote
in deutschland stagniert und trotz das
von ihnen gefeierten kindergeld sie
zuletzt gesunken
gleichzeitig steigen die preise
gleichzeitig sinkt das angebot also es
gibt guten grund dass sie hier das
thematisieren das thema wohneigentum
weil wir natürlich großen wunsch haben
aber einige probleme und da finde ich es
wirklich beeindruckend dass sie das tun
obwohl sie wissen dass wir dann auch
darüber reden was wir letzten 16 jahren
alles nicht gemacht haben und das ist
fast ein selbstloser zug weil wer hat
sie denn eigentlich aufgehalten die
kaffee eigentumsförderung auszubauen wir
kriegen das mit der spd hin wer hat sie
denn aufgehalten die grunderwerbsteuer
freibeträge zu machen wir kriegen das
wieder unser koalitionspartner
da muss man ehrlich sagen wenn wir über
wohneigentum reden und es ist wichtig
dass wir das thematisieren dann müssen
aber auch mal sagen warum deutschland da
steht wo sie steht oder wo man echt
sagen da hilft dir antrag bei der
vergangenheitsbewältigung schon beim
blick in die zukunft nicht
zwei punkte zwei punkte muss sie aber
gesondert rausnehmen weil die haben mich
ein bisschen schockiert
sie aber ihre eigene interpretation des
grunderwerbs freibetrags
für jeden erwachsenen
250.000 euro für jedes kind 150000 euro
eine millionen euro grunderwerbsteuer
freibetrag für eine vierköpfige familie
glauben sie ernsthaft dass einer ihrer
ministerpräsidenten der herr wüst oder
der herr söder auch nur annähernd eine
million euro gewerbesteuer freibetrag
ausreichend wird das ist eine
schaufenster bis ohnegleichen
oder sich und was ich wirklich und was
nicht was mich was ich unanständig
stimmt was ich echt lächerlich finde ich
weiß nicht wie sie darauf pochen aber
dass sie dass sie in sien um ihren wir
würden kind
das ebenso ihren bewährten gegebene
förder versprechen nicht halten also das
baukindergeld denen denen es bewilligt
wurde sei unsicher ich finde das nicht
nur erbärmlich ich finde es unsäglich
der deutsche staat hält sich natürlich
an die verträge dir abgeschlossen hat
das einzige was überraschend kam war das
komplette kfw aus dass sie ausgelöst
haben und da wurde ich zugeben
[Applaus]
bei der kaffee forderung haben wir
tatsächlich haben wir tatsächlich in den
ersten monaten nicht optimal regiert
ja es ist ja im gegensatz zu union hilft
ja selbsterkenntnis beim besser werden
sie auf 16 jahre alles angeschaut haben
nichts gemacht und sind jetzt hier sind
große reden also ja die erst das erste
quartal bei der kfw förderung war nicht
optimal aber jetzt läuft das programm
und die vorarbeiten für ein neues
programm das sich auch die menge der
gesparten auf die gesparte menge co2
konzentriert das technologieoffen ist
dass die menschen mitnimmt dass es in
arbeit das wird kommen und dann lösen
wir auch dem ziel kunst nicht co2
reduktion im bestand und bezahlbarer
wohnraum dafür werden wir komplett neue
förder systematik aufbaut und so bringt
mir das land voran
ich muss natürlich noch mal zurückkommen
zum eigentum
es ist wirklich wichtig und danke dass
sie es formulieren frau ministerin es
ist wirklich wichtig dass wir an den
baukosten rangehen was wir in den
letzten monaten sehr nicht mehr jahre
was wir die letzten monaten gesehen
haben an baukosten bei steigerungen ist
ist absurd deswegen ist es dringend und
das erwarte ich auch vom bauministerium
bmws b weil die allein existenz einen
unterschied machen muss deswegen dieses
dringend dass wir an die baukosten
rangehen wir brauchen den baukosten tüv
wir müssen digitalisieren von der
planung über die genehmigung bis zur
ausführung wir müssen entrümpeln alles
das was bremst time is money
geschwindigkeit hilft und da ist viel zu
tun und das werden die freien demokraten
vorantreiben und dieser regierung aber
was wir jetzt alle erst einmal probe
zielgenau ansetzen werden letzter satz
frau präsidentin marie zielgenau
einsetzen werden ist bei der großen
hürde des eigenkapital auf dem weg ins
eigentum viele viele familien mit den
zinszahlungen einigermaßen zurecht
tilgungszahlungen aber das eigenkapital
ist ein problem deswegen arbeiten wir an
eigenkapital ersetzen darlehen nicht
mehr zurückschlagen entstehen und wir
arbeiten an der grunderwerbsteuer
freibetrag und wenn sie es ernst meinen
mit ihrer wohneigentumsförderung dann
fangen sie jetzt schon an ihre länder zu
überzeugen dass bei der
grunderwerbsteuer mit geht weil ohne
geländer wird darauf im eigenheim nichts
zwar jetzt relativ viele letzte setzte
aber hielt sich noch im rahmen
viele kommata
ich komme noch einmal zurück zum
tagesordnungspunkt
27 und verließen das protokoll dass von
den schriftführerin und schriftführern
ermittelten ergebnisses der namentlichen
abstimmung über die beschlussempfehlung
des auswärtigen ausschusses zu dem
antrag der bundesregierung fortsetzung
der beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte am fähigkeit aufbau der
europäischen union im sahel mit
schwerpunkt
nigeria mali
abgegeben anschuldigungen drucksachen 20
17 62 und 20 18 79 abgegebene stimmen
karten
657 mit ja haben gestimmt
551 mit nein haben gestimmt 100 5
enthaltungen eine die
beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
wir fahren fort in unserer debatte und
als nächster redner bekommt michael
kiessling von der cdu csu das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten kolleginnen kollegen der herr
fürst hat bislang märchenstunde war das
schon wenn sie sagen sie gegen das kfw
förderprogramm auf die reiter gesehen
also in der vergangenheit habe nichts
gesehen die förderprojekte sie machen
hat nichts mit fördern zu tun das hat
eher was mit verhindern zu tun also
schauen sie das mal dass es hinkriegen
und für den haushalt 22 war natürlich
auch sie beteiligt und letztendlich
unser de maria finanzminister olaf
scholz muss machte zu sagen und es hat
auch die sorge dafür tragen müssen dass
diese lücke auch weitergeht also wenn
wir die ampel anschaut und die sehr gut
führende problembeschreibung aber wenig
in der lösungskompetenzen start da muss
man hinkommen
und meine damen meine herren die ampel
ist für den wohnungsbau zuständige und
der wohnungsbau steht momentan auf
dunkelrot da geht nichts voran wir haben
baustopp mit dieser förderpolitik die
zahlen gehen zurück es wird nicht so
gebaut und gebaut werden sollte im
bereich vom klimaschutz weil die
förderung ausbleibt und daran müssen wir
noch arbeiten
wir sind eine situation wo wir steigende
baukosten steigende zinssätze haben
steigende inflation haben steigende
energiekosten haben was verlangt wird
nichts keine antwort im bereich des
wohnungsbaus
deshalb haben wir diesen antrag gestellt
das sind dreimal um den eigentum
natürlich zu fördern es geht auch darauf
auch die baukosten entsprechend
einzugehen und es geht auch darum das
ganze klima schonend zu tun was wir
momentan sehen die förderpolitik oder
besser gesagt bin nicht eure politik
grünen dass bezahlbarer wohnraum
klimaschutz der traum vom eigenen heim
und vor allem das vertrauen in die
politik verloren geht und die selbst
genannte fortschritts koalition macht
genau das gegenteil sie sollten nicht
für den wohnungsmarkt dass der dynamik
reinkommt im gegenteil er wird momentan
ausgebremst
wer solche entscheidung trifft meine
damen in der wohnungspolitik der tritt
auch das quadrat bei tetris anders
gesagt mit sorge entscheidungen kommt
der bau in keinster weise voran
ja ich habe den subtilen hinweis noch
machen sollen zum kollegen meier aber
gut sei mal dahingestellt wir brauchen
verlässlichkeit wir brauchen den heimweg
fort wir brauchen die förderung führen
wie ramon eigentum und letztendlich
müsse man auch auf die
baukostenexplosion
eine antwort finden sie haben gesagt wir
gehen in die zukunft des bauens der bau
muss fortschrittlicher werden alles gut
und richtig wir müssen digitalisieren
auch richtig haben wir auch auf den weg
gebrachten letzten legislaturperiode
aber das hilft uns doch momentan nicht
mit den preisen wir brauchen doch jetzt
auch kurzfristig eine antwort und da
fehlt die antwort kann man sich
vielleicht mal überlegen kann man
steuerlich was tun kann man über
zuschüsse arbeiten wie schaffen wir die
bauwillige entsprechend zu entlassen das
jetzt gebaut wird und dass bauprojekte
nicht verschoben werden wir brauchen die
bau kapazitäten in der baubranche und
der selbst nichts wenn projekte auf die
nächsten jahre verschoben werde meine
damen und herren das schaffen wir nicht
mehr wohnraum
und was wir auch brauchen wir brauchen
investitionsbedingungen die
funktionieren sonderabschreibungen für
energieeffiziente wohngebäude
wir brauchen die anreize das war
interessant die
kollegin von den grünen dass sie fördern
und wie war der begriff fördern und was
hatten sie gesagt an
fördern und unterstützen aber das
unterstützen glaube ich ist dann bei
ihnen ja ich habe auch gesehen ganz
vergessen gibt es auch viel zu aber der
punkt war ja dass sie sagen sie fördern
ambitioniert genau sie fördern
ambitioniert aber die ambitionen bei
ihnen ist er vermutlich das
ordnungsrecht wie schaffe ich die leute
dann dazu entsprechend sei man diese
forderung die sie auf den weg bringen
auch umzusetzen ich glaube wir müssen
anreize schaffen die leute müssen
mitgenommen werden zu bauen und werden
wir sehen welche sanierungsquote dass
wir haben mist schreiben antrag wir
brauchen beides wir brauchen den neubau
wir brauchen wir brauchen die neubau wir
brauchen auch das bauen im bestand die
für stanz nutzung und da ist doch der
punkt wenn die leute gezwungen werden
was zu tun wenn die preise steigen und
wir keine förderung haben dann hilft
auch das ordnungsrecht nicht weil
dadurch wird nicht mehr und am
geschaffen meine damen und herren
schauen sich den antrag noch mal an
nehmen sie die punkte heraus wenn sie
nicht unterstützen können ich glaube
viele gute punkte dabei um wohnraum zu
schaffen eigentum zu schaffen und auch
bezahlbares wohnen mietern im eigentum
entsprechend zu ermöglichen herzlichen
dank an
michael kiessling für die unionsfraktion
in der debatte zum antrag der
unionsfraktionen es geht um die
förderung von wohnungseigentum und es
geht auch das ganze eben hinblick auf
eine effiziente
gebäudeausstattung was das heizen angeht
wir sehen daran gekommen bei einer
daldrup aus der spd-fraktion und da ist
er kommunalpolitischer sprecher unter
anderem nämlich auch sprecher für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauen
cdu/csu das tier des öfteren wir sollten
uns nicht
davon distanzieren dass wir 16 jahren
gemeinsam regiert hat ich will das auch
gar nicht tun und deswegen will ich das
mal ein beispiel deswegen will ich dass
man am beispiel ihres antrags und paar
stellen deutlich machen
vielleicht noch mit der ministerin an
uli lange art vorgestern getwittert wo
ist die ministerin also heute ist sie
auf der regierungsbank gestern war sie
am tag der bauwirtschaft vorgestern habe
ich sie bei der bauingenieur kamera
getroffen und so könnte ich weitermachen
bei den mieterverbänden bei der
wohnungswirtschaft diese minister sucht
den dialog gibt eigene akzente
motiviert und das ist einer der
unterschiede zu ihrem vorgänger der war
glaube ich so eine art phantom der
politik jedenfalls gesehen was nicht
weiter unterschied
ihr antrag tatsächlich den titel den
traum von den eigenen vier wänden
verwirklichen geht noch
eigentumsförderung das ist in ordnung
luczak rumänien nach die höchste quote
die schweiz glaube ich die geringste
wenn man das diskutiert wissen sie genau
quote allein macht's nicht sondern es
geht darum dass man so zu eigentlich nur
für diejenigen die eigentum schaffen
wollen das wollen sie das wollen wir
auch aber wir wollen uns um alle kümmern
die bezahlbaren wohnraum kriegen das ist
der zweite unterschied zu der
vergangenheit für sie sind mieterinnen
und mieter die nutznießer als folge der
eigentumsbildung sozusagen als sicher
effekt aber das wird der herausforderung
heute nicht gerecht das sag ich deutlich
dritter punkt dritter punkt
baukindergeld wir haben das mitgetragen
ich habe es manchmal mehr vorzeitig raus
leute von ihnen fragte marca wegner
fragen sie mal wir wollten auch etwas
für die eigentumsbildung in den städten
tun kauf von genossenschaftsanteilen
damit man sich in der stadt das wohnen
auch leisten kann gescheitert nicht an
der spd nicht am berg am haus seehofers
gescheitert und jetzt im haushalt wird
es drin sein 6 millionen damit geht's
los am kauf von genossenschaftsanteilen
förderung eigentumsbildung stimmen sie
zu
vierter punkt kfw förderung ja das ist
ein kompliziertes thema dran ihr größter
dazu einiges kritisch ist auch
selbstkritisches gesagt aber ich will
mir vielleicht ein sagen die ankündigung
die löste eine antragsflut aus dass in
der tat war das war die ankündigung von
peter altmaier aber davon mal abgesehen
will ich ihnen das noch einmal
vergegenwärtigen dass man hätte tun
müssen 2009/10
86.000 geförderte wohneinheiten
2020 100
97.000 geförderte wohneinheiten
362.000 geförderte wohneinheiten und das
bei einem das mit fünf milliarden
beginnt und mit 16 milliarden auf wird
dann könnte man als verantwortlicher mal
auf die idee kommt man muss aber steuern
wer war da verantwortlich genauer horst
war verantwortlich und peter rahm
verantwortlich und die beiden was haben
sie gemacht gegen den ruf gegenden gegen
die warnungen von gmx haben sie gemacht
und das meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist nicht sinn eines
solchen programmes eines mag an führungs
programms sagt andreas gestaltet werden
muss wird wobei herr merz zum schwimmen
bin voll überzeugt
der sinn der förderung war nämlich in
erster linie ein klimapolitischer und
ein technologischer und nicht einfach
die ungesteuerte eigentumsförderung bis
zum penthouse das war nicht sinn der
sache und die anschlussförderung die
jetzt ja das haben sie beklagt in drei
stunden weg war ist doch ganz zeichen
von atheismus die ist doch ein zeichen
dafür dass akzeptanz und wirksamkeit
dass die bereitschaft klimapolitische
neubauförderung zu machen ankommt und
das müssen wir fortsetzen und das haben
wir in der neuen förderung dargestellt
und das fehlt bei ihm ich glaube dass
das so sagen ich komme zurück zur 1 0
führung grunderwerbsteuer höhe konnte
man ja in den ländern einfach senken in
ihren ländern passiert das genauso wenig
wie den anderen könnte man machen aber
ich will das noch mal sagen daniel hat
das aufgegriffen das worüber sie reden
macht 8 milliarden jedes jahr weniger
einnahmen für die länder aus und aber
lieber gespannt ob sich das placet ihrer
ministerpräsidenten kriegen übrigens
diese grunderwerbsteuer einnahmen nutzen
die länder zu unterstützung und
förderung von eigentums maßnahmen in den
ländern wollen sie vielleicht nicht mehr
kann ja sein also wir haben das jetzt in
den fokus genommen und sie haben es mit
einer gegenfinanzierung verbunden share
deals also wir wollen sozusagen das
nicht nur die kleinen entlastet werden
sondern die großen auch belastet werden
und sie wollen auch die kleinen
entlasten allgemeinheit belasten und die
großen laufen lassen davon bin ich wie
ein
viele ihrer forderungen die in dem
papier stehen sind in unserem
koalitionsvertrag enthalten ich mach
nicht die nummer auf 16 jahre aber ich
bitte um entschuldigung dass in 150
tagen noch nicht alles abgearbeitet
umgesetzt ist das gebe ich freimütig zu
das ist so als auf dem anderen aber wir
machen das schon wir werden uns auch mit
den index mieten beschäftigen damit man
das kleine eigentum das die menschen
haben dass das verfügbare einkommen
nicht noch mehr weggefressen wird habe
ich keinen vorschlag von ihnen zugesehen
es ist nicht die zeit alle steuerlichen
maßnahmen ein zu gehen würde ich gerne
tun aber das klappt nicht mehr
aber ich will zwei sachen sagen die sie
vergessen erstens
sie haben zu der größten blockade der
eigentumsbildung nichts gesagt das sind
die explodierenden bodenpreise nichts
und dazu kommen 25 zweitens wir
verdreifachen wir verdreifachen die
soziale wohnraumförderung diese soziale
wohnraumförderung trägt zu einem drittel
zu eigentums maßnahmen in den ländern
30.000 ins gewesen mit dem
selbstherrlichen zu maßnahmen das
möchten sie offensichtlich in der form
auch nicht und deswegen sage ich mal sie
sind im grunde genommen in der
opposition noch nicht auf dem
erneuerungsprozess angekommen die
erneuerung machen deshalb wird
herzlichen dank
werner daldrup
spd-fraktion wohnungs und baupolitischer
sprecher und kommunalpolitischer
sprecher ist er auch deswegen weise auch
was vor ort die kostentreiber sind wenn
es um das bauen geht nächster redner
casillas allee aus der fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
[Musik]
schön dass ich auch hier sind endlich
nach den zwei harten jahren
um es gleich vorweg zu sagen
horst seehofer und peter altmaier haben
den fokus auf die förderprogramme
komplett falsch eingeschätzt der fokus
lag auf klimaschädliche neubau statt auf
der sanierung aber jetzt meine damen und
herren ist es wichtig diesen
gravierenden fehler zu beseitigen und
den fokus endlich auf der sanierer zu
legen um unsere klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen genau das gehen wir es auch an
die meisten gebäude die 20 45 und so
einen klimaneutralen gebäudebestand
formen werden stehen schon heute in
einer gut durchdachten gebäude förderung
müssen sich diese bereits gebauten
gebäude also unbedingt widerspiegeln
dafür legen wir das ökologische
fundament um diese förderung angemessen
passend und zeitgemäß zu gestalten
wir entwickeln die neubauförderung und
die eigentumsförderung bis zum
jahresende weiter und dabei lassen wir
unsere ideen einen ökologischen bau
wände mit einfließen
das bedeutet lebenszyklus betrachtung
eine faire gebäude förderung und die
kreislaufwirtschaft all das all das
meine damen und herren werden in das
neue programm klimafreundliches bauen
mit einfließen und ich wiederhole es ja
noch mal meine damen und herren das ist
auch bitter nötig im jahr 20 21h der
gebäudesektor 115 millionen tonnen co2
äquivalente emittiert
das sind genau 115 millionen co2 tonnen
zu viel und hauptursache
hauptursache dafür dass wir diese
klimaziele im gebäudesektor wieder mal
verfehlt haben sind die zahlreichen
unsanierten gebäude in unserem land und
hauptursache dafür dass die nicht schon
längst saniert sind ist peter altmaier
um horst seehofer
die folgen dessen die folgen dessen sind
gleichermaßen fatal für unser klima und
für den menschen mit niedrigen einkommen
die jetzt massiv und steigenden
energiepreisen besonders hart betroffen
sind das problem dass vorliegenden
entschließungsantrag der cdu csu
fraktion ist erstens dass er vieles
fordert was wir bereits angepackt haben
und genau deshalb ist es auch ein
schaufensterantrag
zweitens und wichtigen ist das teilweise
will die union mit diesem antrag in eine
förder vergangenheit zurück die uns alle
heute aufgezeigten probleme auch
eingebracht hat und daher meine damen
und herren gehen wir diesen antrag
entschieden noch zurück vielen dank
casillas alle für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen
es wird weiter diskutiert über einen
antrag der unionsfraktionen es geht um
die förderung von wohneigentum es geht
um die
effiziente heizung aus statt um
beispielsweise in zeiten steigender
energiepreise und zum thema jetzt konrad
stockmeier aus der fdp fraktion dass ich
da pfiff diesmal wieder anhört als ob es
die spatzen von den dächern trällern
denn liebe kollegen von der union das
ist wieder ein antrag der nur darauf
hinweist was sie in ihrer vergeht
regierungsverantwortung nicht auf die
reihe gekriegt haben denn nämlich
wirklich eine langfristig orientierte
wohnungsbauförderung aufs gleis zu
setzen die effizienten klimaschutz
wirklich dient ganz kurzer blick zurück
auch daran sei noch mal erinnert alle
anträge die du zu wissen die bis zu
diesem stopp im januar bei der kfw
eingegangen sind werden ja noch
bearbeitet dafür sind sage und schreibe
noch mal fünf milliarden euro
mobilisiert worden und lassen sie uns
aber nun anders als es in ihrem antrag
geschieht wirklich mal den blick nach
vorne richten und dabei wird klar dass
die voerder systematik wirklich
weiterentwickelt werden muss sowohl aus
techno logischen und das möchte ich
betonen aber auch aus fiskalischen
gründen
denn nicht nur diesen sondern auch viele
andere anträge aus ihren reihen
durchziehen mittlerweile parteipolitisch
gesprochen fehlten die sowas von tief
rot schimmern dass man sich nur noch
wundern kann denn sie schmeißen auch
wieder in diesem antrag mit geld um sich
als ob es kein morgen gäbe aber es gibt
in diesem land ein morgen in dem die
menschen energie effizient klimaschonend
und bezahlbare wohnen können sollen und
deshalb bringen wir wie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart eine
grundlegende neuausrichtung der voerder
systematik auf den weg die sich und das
ist für uns liberale besonders wichtig
auch technologieoffen an der jeweiligen
einspar menge von co2 orientieren wird
in wirklich wirklich gut gestaltete und
auch in der laufzeit definierte
förderung schafft markt anreize und
stärkt die wirtschaftlichkeit der
implementierten lösungen und zur
wahrheit gehört aber auch dazu das ist
auch hier ein thema ist bei dem
verschiedene politikbereiche ineinander
greifen müssen um das problem zu lösen
also beispielsweise qualifizierung und
auch qualifizierte einwanderung um den
fachkräftemangel zu überwinden die
ampelkoalition ist dran forschung
beispielsweise auch die stärkung der
hochschulen für angewandte
wissenschaften die gerade im baubereich
sehr innovativ unterwegs sind die ampel
ist dran und beispielsweise auch die
vereinfachung von vorschriften und da
kann ich als baden württemberger aus dem
wahlkreis mannheim nur auf die
landesbauordnungen verweisen wenn es
sich mal an ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen in stuttgart da gibt es viel zu
tun und was ist von alldem in ihrem
antrag zu finden nichts
und der rückwärtsgewandtheit ihres
antrages halte ich entgegen was die
deutsche gesellschaft für nachhaltiges
bauen jüngst in einer aktuellen
stellungnahme der ampelkoalition mit auf
den weg gegeben hat ich zitiere mit
erlaubnis der frau präsidentin
der bundesregierung können wir nur
zurufen halten sie kurs halten sie den
druck aus und gehen sie diesen weg
weiter wir brauchen die umstellung auf
die zielgröße co2 und die lebenszyklus
betrachtung um zielgerichtet planen
bauen sanieren und gebäude betreiben zu
können dem schließe ich mich an vielen
dank
für die cdu csu fraktion erhält jetzt
das wort an die könig
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sowohl
bei weniger als auch die baubranche
stehen derzeit vor drei großen
herausforderungen zum einen sind es die
extrem lieferengpässe von baumaterial
zum anderen die explodierenden
energiepreise die auch das bauen massiv
verteuern und drittens ein
fachkräftemangel der sich durch alle
segmente der branche zieht und als ob
das nicht noch
und als ob das nicht auch schlimm genug
wäre hat dann die ampel noch einen drauf
das wackelt mit dem drama und den kfw
förderstopp sie haben in der tat ein
trauerspiel in drei akten zustande
gebracht der erste beginnt am 24 januar
in einer hauruck aktion des
wirtschaftsministeriums wurde der
sofortiges kfw förderstopp für
energieeffiziente gebäude war über die
homepage verkündet was nicht nur ein
kommunikations desaster war sondern
zugleich ein schwerer vertrauensbruch
gegenüber bauwilligen und vor allem
gegenüber jungen familien die glaubten
dass ihre finanzierung auf sicheren
füßen stehe
und ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich so geht
noch nicht mit der lebensplanung junger
menschen in diesem land um der
wirtschaftsminister versuchte sich
daraufhin in schadensbegrenzung
er kündigte die fortsetzung der
förderung zumindest für den standard e h
40 beim neubau an es wurde also
umdisponiert neue energie berater wurden
beauftragt neue finanzierungen wurden
abgeschlossen natürlich jetzt zu
schlechteren bedingungen
aber es folgte der zweite akt des dramas
nach drei monaten langen wartens wurde
innerhalb von drei stunden die
neubauförderung für e h 40 erneut
gestoppt da die eine milliarde euro die
dazu zur verfügung gestellt wurde schon
ausgeschöpft war reichen sollte das geld
ja eigentlich nicht nur für drei stunden
sondern bis zum jahresende
diese kleine fehleinschätzung oder
katastrophale fehleinschätzung wie ich
finde des ministeriums war für viele
betroffene ein echter schlag in die
magengrube und ließ den traum vom
eigenen heim endgültig zu platzen
und damit sind wir auch schon beim
dritten akt jetzt gibt es nur noch eine
neubauförderung in kombination mit einem
qualitätssiegel für nachhaltiges bauen
wiederum unter verschlechterten
förderbedingungen
diese dürfen nur von
zertifizierungsstellen ausgestellt
werden von denen ist genau drei in
deutschland gibt zudem ist dieses
verfahren extrem langwierig und
kostspielig damit motivieren sie gerade
nicht zum klimafreundlichen bauen
sondern sie schrecken eher davon ab
die von der regierung merkel
eingeführten förderprogramme haben dafür
gesorgt dass sich mehr menschen für
effiziente gebäudesanierung entschieden
haben wir haben damit einen ganz
entscheidenden beitrag für den
klimaschutz geleistet ihr fördert chaos
führt dazu dass sich weniger menschen in
zukunft energieeffizienz leisten können
sie betreiben damit eine politik gegen
effizienz und gegen klimaschutz
zudem sendet die ampel ein fatales
signal für die wohnungs und baubranche
ihre politik führt zu auftragseinbrüchen
für mittelständler und handwerker wenn
fest eingeplante zuschüsse wegfallen
werden nicht nur privatleute sondern
auch wohnungsbaugesellschaften ihre
pläne verwerfen und sie halten ganz
trotzig an ihrem ziel jährlich 400.000
neue wohnungen zu bauen aufrecht aber
tun zugleich eigentlich gar nichts dafür
dass das überhaupt noch funktionieren
kann das an sich ja auch christen
richtige ziel der klimaneutralität im
gebäudebestand bis 2050 rückt doch so
auch immer in weiter entfernte
gegenden es reicht eben auch nicht aus
auf feierliche erklärung auf
internationalen klimakonferenzen
abzuheben oder wohlklingende bündnisse
für bezahlbares bauen auszurufen
klimaschutz gelingt in erster linie im
baubereich nur mit unseren handwerkern
bauunternehmern und bauherren vor ort
die ist ganz konkret
die politik muss die energiewende auch
nicht alleine schultern aber sie muss
den machern vor ort zumindest
verlässlichkeit und planungssicherheit
geben beides leider fremdworte für die
ampeln
es ist es so die von ihnen verursachte
stagnation in der bauwirtschaft zieht in
unserer volkswirtschaft zwangsläufig
noch weitere branchen in mitleidenschaft
wir fordern sie daher in unserem antrag
auf reißen sie das ruder jetzt endlich
herum und sorgen sie wieder für die
richtigen rahmenbedingungen beim bauen
und sanieren in deutschland wenn eine
steigende inflation investieren teurer
macht dann benötigen die bauwilligen
jungen familien aber auch die bau- und
wohnungsbrände die unterstützung des
staates jetzt in besonderem maße mit
unseren anträgen liefern wir vorschläge
die das von der ampel verursachte
desaster abmildern können wir bieten
ihnen damit einen ausweg aus ihrer
tragödie sie müssen lediglich dafür
unseren anträgen zustimmen vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
an der könig aus der unionsfraktion und
wir nähern uns schon langsam aber sicher
lehre ist so ganz so ganz so weit ist es
noch gar nicht mehr
beweglich ist die nächste rednerin und
danach folgen erst mal noch drei also
melanie wirklich aus der spd-fraktion
und wie spricht jetzt
die union verspricht den traum der
eigenen vier wände der titel des
antrages mag ja eigentlich ganz gut
scheinen aber leider eben nur auf den
ersten blick gehen wir mal in die
details sie schreiben dass wir den
erwerb von immobilien für familien mit
geringen und mittleren einkommen fördern
wollen das klingt ja zunächst auch mal
ganz gut aber war ehrlich wo können sich
geringverdiener überhaupt noch
wohneigentum leisten ihn ist schon klar
dass für viele familien ohne den
ausblick auf eine erbschaft ihr
sogenannter traum ein echter kampf wenn
ich sogar völlig utopisch ist
wie hoch müsste die förderung des
staates sein um diese familien zu
erreichen das ist augenwischerei
so eine förderung kommt nur
spitzenverdienern zugute und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch der ganze sinn und
zweck dieses antrag ist schauen wir uns
das mal genauer
eine erzieherin im anerkennungsjahr
verdient monatlich so zirka 1500 euro
brutto damit gehört es in meinem
bundesland hessen gerade so noch zu den
menschen die an geförderte mietwohnungen
beantragen können und die union will
hier jetzt aber ein eigenheim anpreisen
das ist doch zynisch und vollkommen an
qualität vorbei
aber bekäme sie dann ja in hessen
überhaupt eine geförderte wohnung
wahrscheinlich nicht denn in hessen sind
die sozial mietwohnung über die letzten
zehn jahre und 35 prozent zurückgegangen
das ist doch die eigentliche baustelle
und wer stellt er gleich noch mal den
ministerpräsidenten die antragstellenden
fraktionen
es ist immer leicht mehr mittel vom bund
zu fordern aber es muss dann halt auch
in den ländern geliefert werden menschen
mit geringen einkommen brauchen
bezahlbaren wohnraum und keine
luftschlösser in form von unions
anträgen
aber zurück zu genau diesem antrag sie
wollen mehr bauland aufbrach und
konversionsflächen gewinnen ist ihnen
bewusst dass es in ballungsräumen also
dort wo auch die arbeitsplätze für die
angesprochenen menschen mit geringen und
mittleren einkommen sind so gut wie gar
keine brachflächen gibt kommunale
diskussionen beschäftigen sich
mittlerweile längst mit der frage
inwieweit man flächen versiegeln kann
beziehungsweise darf hier mal die
abwägung zwischen der nachfrage nach
wohnraum einerseits und der
lebensqualität andererseits nur als
stichwort
angeblich also vorhandenen flächen mit
staatlich geförderten einfach in den
häusern zuzupflastern die dann auch noch
für die vorgegebenen kleine mittleren
einkommen völlig unerreichbar sind ist
nicht nur realitätsfern sondern auch
unaufrichtig
ihren antrag aus diesen gründen
abzulehnen ist ganz einfach aber ich
möchte auch darauf eingehen was wir
stattdessen werden die ampel regierung
setzt sich dafür ein dass es wieder mehr
sozialwohnungen gibt wir wollen den
ablauf des sozial wohnungsbestandes
bremsen und umkehren deshalb werden wir
den sozialen wohnungsbau der länder bis
20 26 mit einer rekord summe von 14 5
milliarden euro fördern
darin sind auch die mitte für das bund
länder programm für studentisches und
der auszubildenden wonach dem programm
jahr 2023 enthalten schon dieses jahr
packt die ampel zwei milliarden euro in
den sozialen wohnungsbau davon eine
milliarde euro in den klimagerechten
sozialen wohnungsbau das klingt für mich
doch schon viel eher nach sinnvoll
investierte geld in diesem sinne packen
mit an vielen dank
als nächste rednerin folgt für bündnis
90/die grünen christina johannes
schröder
[Applaus]
liebe union sie haben jetzt ein paar
verbale vorschlag herausgeholt und die
möchte ich jetzt doch zum ende der
debatte noch mal einordnen also erst mal
haben sie die ministerin extrem falsch
zitiert uns war so falsch dass es
einfach unwahr ist die ministerin hat
völlig richtig gesagt dass nicht jede
generation so viel fläche verbrauchen
kann dass sie ihre eigenen eigenheim
bauen kann sondern dass die alten
saniert werden müssen wir haben ja jetzt
endlich wieder
wir haben jetzt ja endlich wieder gäste
ninja und debattieren nicht nur mit uns
und die jungen leute die hier sitzen von
den schulen haben auch ein anrecht
darauf zu überlegen was sie mit irland
fläche machen es geht aber nicht wenn
wir deutschland zu gebaut haben
[Applaus]
dann frau könig eine wenn eine milliarde
im drei stunden weg ist dann war das
unglaublich relativ erfolgreiche
förderprogramm das zeigt wie wahnsinnig
gut unsere bauwirtschaft eben effizient
wohnung raum schaffen kann ich glaube
das ist ganz wichtig dass wir eben die
milliarden nutzen um eine neue förderung
auf die beine zu stellen und noch dürfen
sie an die zwischenfrage aus der
cdu-fraktion verlieren wird
vielen dank frau kollegin dass die
zwischenfrage zu lassen sie haben wir
jetzt gerade auf die bauwirtschaft
reguliert und dass sie ja so toll damit
umgehen kann mit dem programm da würde
ich sie erlauben bald ganz kurz ein
zitat aus einer pressemitteilung des gwb
verhalten der genivi ist ja bekanntlich
ist der hat der verband die sozusagen
die aus ihrer sicht zu sein die guten
wohnungsunternehmen die sozial
aufgestellten wohnungsunternehmen ihren
vertreten und dann will ich in der tat
manchmal vorhalten dort wird formuliert
dringender denn je ist das förderkreis
beim klima schonenden bezahlbaren bauen
zuwenden planbarkeit ist
grundvoraussetzung für das entstehen von
neuen wohnraum dafür ist eine wirksame
verlässliche förder systematik dringend
notwendig das fiasko rund um die fifa
hat jetzt schon verzögerung von bis zu
zwölf monaten bei bauten
modernisierungen verursacht die nicht
mehr aufzuholen sind wenn man wenn man
so etwas jetzt hört dann ist da noch ein
gewisser widerspruch zu dem was sie
sagen dass die bauwirtschaft so toll
damit umgehen kann richtig ist es doch
dass wir mit einem riesigen atheismus
haben dass zwei drittel der projekte
momentan so ruhig gestellt werden bei
keiner genau weiß was denn eigentlich
die förderbedingungen ab 1 die ersten 20
23 sein und da würde ich mir schon mal
interessieren wie sie diesen widerspruch
eigentlich auflösen wollen genau also
tatsächlich erst recht differenziert
zwischen bau- und wohnungswirtschaft
also erstmals total gut möglich
klimaeffizienz auf den kfw 40 standard
zu bauen und das nächste problem ist
total war der gdw sagt etwas völlig war
es aber das voerder chaos das haben wir
ja nicht verursacht
im angriff wohnungs und bau politik hier
im bundestag zu machen und das erste was
ich getan hat war eine unfassbare
krisenkommunikation weil über zehn
milliarden euro in ein völlig
überfordertes programm gesteckt worden
und wir einfach als haushalt lieber denn
dieses parlament stimmt im haushalt kein
geld
so und dass deswegen hat minister
altmaier das haben meine kollegen schon
mehrfach gesagt während er noch regiert
hat dieses förderprogramm gestoppt es
hatte keine steuerungswirkung mehr es
hat
wahnsinnig viel steuergeld verschlungen
und es hat ganz bestimmt nicht die
wirkung gehabt eigenheim zu fördern hin
und wieder zufällig mal aber es ist eine
subvention der wohnungswirtschaft
gewesen ist in ordnung aber sie haben
das bundesförderprogramm für effiziente
gebäude dafür zweckentfremdet härter
durch
[Applaus]
wir machen das ja auch ich glaube das
haben alle meine vorredner schon gesagt
aus der ampelkoalition
eigentumsbildung ist uns wichtig wir
werden aber die förderung einmal
komplett auf neue füße stellen müssen
denn das was wir von ihm übernommen
haben das reicht einfach nicht
wir wollen das 1,5 grad ziel halten das
sind wir der generation die dort oben
sitzt verpflichtet denn der klimawandel
bedrohten ganz konkret den traum vom
eigenheim das wissen alle die in
rheinland-pfalz oder nordrhein-westfalen
von dem schlimmen hochwasser betroffen
waren im letzten jahr die haben ihr
eigenheim ihre erinnerungen ihre
rentenvorsorge all das haben sie verlor
und durch den klimawandel deswegen ist
es wichtig dass die bundesförderung für
effiziente gebäude in zukunft effiziente
gebäude fördert nicht nur den neubau
und das ist gut dass wir das jetzt
machen wir stellen die bundesförderung
für effiziente gebäude neu auf wir
machen eine richtlinie für förderung von
pilotprojekten der serien sanieren wir
machen eine bundesförderung für
wärmenetze wir machen ein gesetz zur
kommunalen vermittlung und wir machen
ein aufbauprogramm und qualifikations
offensive für wärmepumpe und dann klappt
das auch mit dem klimafreundlichen büro
das ist aber nicht nur aus bezahlbarkeit
gründen wichtig das ist eben auch
wichtig weil wir gerade eine große
geopolitisch abhängigkeit haben vor
explodierenden gaspreisen wurde immer
wieder gewarnt vor der hohen
abhängigkeit von putins gas im
wohnbereich wurde immer wieder gewarnt
und dank ihres nicht handeln werden wir
bis 2000 permanent klimaziele reißen
selbst wenn wir alle ressourcen die wir
haben jetzt in effiziente förderung von
gebäuden stecken
wir wollen eigentlich fördern das ist
uns wichtig und ich finde es sehr gut
dass der finanzminister gerade mit den
ländern bezüglich der grunderwerbsteuer
verhandelt und wir wollen eine neue
eigenkapital förderung auflegen und das
genossenschafts programm ich glaube
damit haben wir schon die ersten
grundsteine gelegt was wir tun müssen
ist die bodenpreise senken denn das
macht wohnen neben der inflation und dem
baustoff mangel extrem teuer und die
wir müssen schert hills unterbinden und
wir müssen kommunen dazu befähigen dass
sie im boden vor bevorratung betreiben
können und wir müssen uns mal die
maklervertrag angucken in anderen
ländern sind das so 2% in wer bestellt
bezahlt
in deutschland ist sie gestiegen seit
des gesetzes was die grupo 2000
abgeschlossen so von 6 auf mit 7 prozent
das muss man sich mal vorstellen das
sind die üblichen erwerbs kreisen 30.000
euro das ist ein wunderschönes
eigenkapital welches wir reguliert
dringend regulieren sollten liebe union
wir kümmern uns jetzt dass das klappt
mit dem klimafreundlichen brunnen wir
kümmern uns jetzt dass es klappt mit der
eigentumsförderung und wir kümmern uns
jetzt dass es klappt das die energie
preise senken ich glaube damit haben wir
ein großes programm mit dem wir
zusammenarbeiten
christina johanna schröder war das für
bündnis 90 die grünen hier in der
debatte wie
wohneigentum gefördert werden kann
nächster redner ist aus der
unionsfraktion die hier auch den antrag
eingereicht hat und ich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr verehrt
bei ministerin es muss ja einen
unterschied machen wie der kollege fürst
gesagt hat ob man ein ministerium hat
oder nicht hat deswegen
respektieren wir dass sie sich der
heutigen debatte stellen ich sage ihnen
aber auch ganz offen all die bauwilligen
hätten auch ihren respekt verdient
gehabt in den letzten wochen und monaten
bevor dieses chaos ausgebrochen ist
vergangenen mittwoch hat das
statistische bundesamt die neuen zahlen
gemeldet minus 8,9 prozent weniger
genehmigungen für neue wohnungen
neubauten und umbauten
minus
26,2 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat bei einfamilienhäusern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen minus
26,2 prozent dh hier sind die geplatzten
träume die sie zu verantworten haben
und das liegt an der verkürzten
förderpolitik und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der spd ich frage natürlich wo
war die ministerin beim förderstopp
diese frage muss erlaubt sein denn wer
war denn der finanzminister der das
programm hinterlegt hat das war olaf
scholz der bundeskanzler hätte jetzt ein
machtwort sprechen können für ein
programm das wir gemeinsam aufgesetzt
haben das haben wir nicht getan hat er
gezögert und gezaudert und es kommt
nichts lieber kollege der druck des
wegen eklatanter vertrauensbruch und
wütende protestschreiben der menschen
aus all unseren wahlkreisen die einfach
bitter enttäuscht wurden von der neuen
regierung und liebe ministerin ich
zitiere sie richtig ökonomisch und
ökologisch unsinnig wenn jede generation
neue einfamilienhäuser baut ja aber
minus 26,2 prozent kann nicht unsinnig
sein wenn ich mir anschaue wie groß die
lücke ist am neuen wohnungen an
einfamilienhäusern denn so werden wir
auch das problem steigen der mieten
nicht in den griff bekommen wenn weniger
gebaut wird werden die mieten definitiv
nicht sinken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und wenn sie dann auch nicht
energieeffizient bauen wird auch nicht
funktionieren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der grünen sie können doch kein
interesse daran haben dass die menschen
nicht mal mehr standard 55 bauen weil
sie sich nicht leisten können sie bauen
noch weniger das ist doch nicht ihre
politik das ist doch nicht ihr anspruch
sie scheitern in den ersten tagen schon
an sich selber das ist nicht sozial und
nicht ökologisch was sie uns bisher hier
vorgelegt habe
der traum vom eigenheim schutz vor
altersarmut der traum vom eigenheim ist
familienpolitik
75 prozent derer die bei kindergeld
bezogen haben haben ein einkommen von
weniger als 60.000 euro
35 jahre war das durchschnittsalter der
antragsteller
1,7 kinder
400.000 anträge
710000 kinder haben ein eigenes dach
über den kopf bekommen das ist union das
ist familienpolitik und deren
fortsetzung erwarten wir auch von der
ampel mit planungssicherheit mit den
förderprogrammen
vermitteln und wieder sich darauf
verlassen können was regierungen was der
deutsche bundestag beschließt sie haben
einen anspruch auf ein ende dieses
hauses machen sie weiter endlich mit dem
brachflächen programm das hilft gegen
die bodenpreise da haben sie da haben
sie liebe kollegen der druck in der
letzten periode
gebremst sie waren der bremse an diese
stelle
neubauförderung die benutzungs schließen
ein rege neuen start menschen träumen
weiter von ihren eigenen vier wänden
herzlichen dank
ulrich lange kriegt hier viel applaus
von seiner fraktion
für diese rede und mal sehen wie das
beim nächsten redner aussieht ist es der
letzte reden bevor hier die abgeordneten
abstimmen timon gremmels für die
spd-fraktion
kollegen ich bin richtig froh dass ich
andere träume aber als die friedrich
merz in die cdu csu fraktion also ich
meine wählerinnen und wähler die träumen
von bezahlbaren wohnen das ist der traum
der mehrheit dieser menschen und
bezahlbare wohnung inkludiert und fast
natürlich auch im einzelfall das
eigenheim was man selber bauen möchte
aber ehrlich gesagt wenn es ihnen um die
sache gegangen wäre wenn sie ordentlich
auch eine revision gemacht hätten was
sie die letzten 16 jahre getan oder eben
nicht getan hätten wenn sie sich in der
sache korrigieren und verbessern wollen
dann hätte ich mir bei anderen antrag
gewünscht dass sie es wirklich nötig
haben sind entsteht zu zitieren und
damit ihren antrag einzubringen das hat
er in die minister hier schon deutlich
gemacht das ist etwas wofür sie sich
schämen sollten meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren dass sie sowas wird ja
so was kennen wir eigentlich nur vom
ganz rechten zeit dieses hauses und ich
bin ehrlich froh dass wir eine eigene
bau ministerin haben oder eben das nicht
mehr ein alex ist ans innenministerium
wie das unter horst seehofer oder der
fall war wir haben da wir gesagt dass
dieses thema ausgewertet wird das wäre
ein eigenes haus haben dass wir eine
engagierte ministerin haben die ideen
und konzepte hier vorstellt auf die wir
unter vier jahre lang gewartet abend und
nicht nur wir zu hunderten menschen in
diesem land und sich dann jetzt hier
hinzustellen und noch geschichts
revision zu betreiben wer hat denn im
november letzten jahres dieses kfw
förderprogramm zum 31 dieses jahres
auslaufen lassen wer war als wer war der
minister kein wort nicht einmal ist der
name peter altmaier von ihnen gefallen
hat wird vier redner haben wir
gesprochen nach zehn minuten haben sie
geredet sie haben weder über den
bauminister horst seehofer gesprochen
noch über den für das gebäude
energiegesetz zuständigen
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier sie
haben ihre eigene ihre eigenen minister
sozusagen hier und die reifenteile
geschichte überhaupt nicht im blick
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
von der lancken dann frage ich sie was
er hat denn horst seehofer gemacht um
die 800.000 bau überhänge kurzfristig
abzuarbeiten was war denn das was sie da
geliefert haben nichts und naturnahe
ordentlichen aufarbeitung die eigene
regierungsverantwortung gehört auch die
kritische selbst befassung und ich gebe
ihnen ja zu das ist ein kommunikatives
nicht die gerade die glanzleistung war
mit dem kfw programm gar keine frage wir
haben da auch vertrauen verspielt aber
dass eine gemeinschaftliche
verantwortung und da haben die sich
entzog meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ihm geht es hier nicht um die
sache geht es hier um billige
oppositionspolitik und das ehrlich das
ist aus meiner sicht zu wenig wir
beschäftigen uns umfassend mit dieser
thematik und wir gucken dass wir nach
vorne blicken und ich sage ihnen mal was
aus meinem eigenen wahlkreis wenn ich
bei mir im ländlichen raum unterwegs bin
habe ich folgendes phänomen die
ortskerne der dörfer bluten aus weil die
häuser zu klein sind weil sie nicht mehr
den ansprüchen von heute genügen bei
teilweise denkmalschutzauflagen da sind
oder den ortsrändern sollen neue
baugebiete entstehen wir müssen doch
gucken dass wir auch die ortskerne
stärken dass wir programme entwickeln
wie man auch im dorfkern gut und modern
und sicher leben kann wie man
energetisch sanieren kann wie man auch
gucken dass wir die menschen dorthin
bringen und nicht immer aus fragen sind
weitere neue wohngebiete haben meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren darum
müssen wir uns kümmern und deswegen
müssen wir uns in der tat wieder
angebote schaffen und was ist noch
erlebe werde ich bei mir im ort
unterwegs bin dass ganz viele
mittlerweile ältere ehepaare oder auch
witwen und witwer in den ganz großen
häusern alleine leben weil es eben keine
kleinen wohnungen gibt die sich auch
nicht mehr kaufen wollen die sie mieten
wollen und dann bestandsbauten frei
machen würden die familien darüber
müssen wir uns und darum müssen wir uns
kümmern auch das ist ein traum den die
menschen haben die sehr verehrten damen
und herren davon ist in ihrem antrag auf
das wenig zu lesen und dann müssen wir
gucken dass wir auch all das was wir tun
in der tat zu tun dass wir hier als
energieeffizient machen es hilft doch
jetzt nicht schnell und preiswert zu
bauen und dann die folgekosten die
energiekosten von morgen sind die
menschen genauso belasten wir haben
kredite abbezahlen müssen auch darum
müssen wir uns kümmern auch da reden wir
viel zu wenig von ihnen und deswegen ist
es richtig dass diese koalition sich zum
ziel gesetzt hat mehr zu bauen bezahlbar
zu bauen dass wir 400.000 neue wohnungen
schaffen als wir es gemeinschaftlich
machen und dass wir nachhaltig machen
dafür stehen wir bereit dafür steht die
ampel koalition
da werden ja auch niemand in diesem
senat ist gut gelaufen
[Applaus]